i'm too british i think i like crisps
the most that's my favorite snack
walker's crisps yeah walker's crisps are
amazing we have so many good crisps in
the uk
because it's like a national like
identity like every single lunch must
have a bag of christmas not chips
crisps crisps crisps nah they're called
cheers we have so many good brands of
crisps like i [ __ ] love monster munch
i love
mccoys the monster sounds epic do
monster mods
i will say i'll say the best best crisp
i miss
walkers max paprika flavor they're just
mccoys kind of but like lighter
like mccoy's like thick no no no like
because like walker's max has like this
sound [ __ ] stupid to any americans
they're like what are they saying
the walkers the walkers max crisps have
like the right amount of like
oiliness to them yeah it's just it's
just like it's a little
it's a little unhealthy it's kind of
weird because like we give like
you know i don't know what the standard
lunch is in australia or america
yeah but like if you ever have a lunch
in the uk it normally just comes with
crisps
it's like a given school lunch
lunches and you come with a bag of
crisps oh yeah um i mean yeah i guess
like
you know i used to eat like chips and
stuff during like lunch and stuff but
then it's really common as well to have
tons of
always like it comes with the lunch it's
such a staple in the british
license like salt flavored or no they we
have so many flavors and
i think they're amazing i've i've yet to
find many brands of crisps that i don't
like in the uk right like quavers i love
quavers
i love even though you have to buy so
quavers have you seen these before
basically like cheese flavored like thin
skulls
yeah they're cheese flavored but they're
not they don't taste anything like
cheetos
no no it's like a much lighter yeah you
can eat like seven bags in one sitting
no problem because it just tastes like
air
right the whole thing is like it's light
and has like two calories yeah it has
like two bites in the bags yeah yeah
yeah
yeah that's what it looks like yeah
cause like yeah they're [ __ ] amazing
bro
never seen those are okay uh we have
like these
palm bears what are they called they're
they're in france as well bears yeah
like the bears crisp they're just better
i've never seen them they're really good
what the [ __ ] are they they're in europe
too
yeah they're german right but the other
british ones the monster munch is my
favorite
chris loves monster munch too i think
and mccoy's he's pretty british though
yeah mccoy's is okay i still i still
stand by the walk as much
let me google british crisps this is so
[ __ ] many i'm like
this it's been like a [ __ ] tangent
hasn't it yeah yeah we have so many
people
all australians watching this can agree
that the best chips we have
is red rock dilly chips that's like the
one that is the one brand that i've
seen since the beginning of my career i
will happily sell out we recently but
about at this time just before i left we
recently started having a boom of like
high-end crisps in the uk oh you mean
the kettle chips yeah yeah chips
tyrells are like massive now yeah yeah
uk called tyrells you sometimes see them
in japan they import them really
as like premium british cruises there's
also french they're called french fries
yeah yeah yeah do you have these i think
so they're just like crisps that are
shaped like yeah
they're really [ __ ] good i don't
think they're called french fries though
there's like a different brand you have
uh
squares by walkers oh squares [ __ ]
love
okay okay now you're talking now you're
talking
dude that's so good squares i'll put
salty squirts and the salt and vinegar
ones are super [ __ ] salty
okay uh they have salt and vinegar uh
prawn cocktail and
cheese and onion prawn cocktail i've
realized cheese and onion is a very like
british flavor [ __ ] cheese is like
the best [ __ ] because we don't have
cheese and onion flavored stuff in
australia dude you're missing out
is honestly like the best of the best
the one
the one brand of chips that i thought
was [ __ ] awesome was when i was in
ireland i had potatoes
potatoes i think that's a specific
island specific to ireland but the
cheese and flavor potatoes
man orgasmic they're so [ __ ] good
but wait yeah wait [ __ ] what was we on
before that
squares squares squares squares are
really nice uh we also have
hula hoops all the hoops they have these
in america i'm pretty sure they do
they're just the ones you put on your
they can fit on your fingers they're
like rings oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah we have knickknacks i
really like knickknacks
i've never had those people that's a
very like uh like marmalade
coated crisps marmalade right i think
it's what it is
is that what it is i can't remember what
it is that sounds weird
what are they called what's it's in
america as well i think they have what's
it like cheetos
yeah they kind of feel like cheetos but
uh
jacob minis are sensations
i remember sensations oh my god they had
like premium
bagged crisps yeah but these are all
like walker's brands right yeah they're
all one
yeah because walkers just like walkers
is what are they called in america again
i wish we had this conversation last
week when shu was here because i don't
have another australian to relate to
damn it people have like apparently
there's so many news organizations in
the uk have done
uh tier lists of crisps from like bottom
tier to like heights oh that's a that's
an after dark
stream we also had a bag of crisps that
was really popular
it was called salt and shake that was
like a bag of crisps that we hadn't been
salted and it would come with salt and
the whole gimmick of this thing was that
you put the salt in it
you should shake it up yeah you saw
you'd literally salt it yourself
right right right and it tastes like
[ __ ] yeah
because it was like it was just unsalted
evenly like it was the salt would stick
to like the bottom
and then the rest of the sauce just at
the bottom yeah yeah it is terrible
but like yeah it's like if you come to
the uk i really highly recommend trying
all our crisps
yeah i don't really rate the japanese
ones too much nah they're pretty bad uh
the pizza potato one's pretty good yeah
that's what i'd say only the pizza
cheese i don't know why you like the
pizza potato ones
yeah i told chris i was like uh next
video that i want to make with him is uh
trying all the japanese crisps
just two [ __ ] super british people
complaining about crisps
because there's a lot of like meh ones
here yeah
most of the ones you find here are just
pretty meh especially the ones in from
like the combination
the flavors they have are so bizarre and
they have doritos here but they're like
taco flavored
and it does not taste like taco well
they have cheetos here as well but it
doesn't taste like
that's not about like pizza flavored
stuff i mean what what is the flavor of
pizza anyway
right it's rust yeah no crust no no no
no crust apparently
not a single [ __ ] crust in sight mate
you won't see a crust
you should love it technically there's
no crust i mean it's
not i mean it's a pizza you know a pizza
it's a pizza you need the crust in the
pizza just not the crust by itself it's
you hearing this this man's stuff
i'm not i'm not going to start we're not
going to start talking about [ __ ]
pizza crusts again
we've moved on we've evolved